so what exactly are these gravitational
waves that everyone's been getting so
excited about recently how did we
discover them and why should you even
care let me fill you in 100 years ago a
man called Albert Einstein you might
have heard of him
published his theory of general
relativity you may currently think of
space and time as being two separate
things but according to his theory they
are intrinsically woven together to
create the very fabric of the universe
called space-time very inventive now
Einstein also predicted that if you have
a big enough gravitational event let's
say a star exploding then that event
would create ripples in space-time sort
of like when you drop a rock in a pond
and it creates ripples on the surface
the difference being that in our
exploding star scenario these are
ripples of gravity known as
gravitational waves and they literally
Bend and stretch the space-time as they
travel outwards it's a really really
cool idea and it's one that scientists
have accepted and been using for a long
time already but the problem with it is
that in the grand scheme of the universe
gravity is an incredibly weak force
which makes it incredibly difficult to
observe in fact Einstein himself said
that he didn't think we would ever be
able to see these gravitational waves
how wrong he was now what we're gonna do
is we're gonna go back in time over a
billion years we're gonna travel to a
galaxy far far away and we're gonna find
two black holes in orbit around each
other black holes in and of themselves
already have a huge gravitational force
they are so powerful that if you get
close enough to one it is absolutely
impossible to escape them like even
light itself gets dragged inside of
these things what we have here are two
black holes in orbit around each other
getting closer and closer to one another
and spinning faster and faster as they
get closer until eventually they're
spinning it very nearly almost the speed
of light and then that is the actual
sound that they made these two black
holes collided and created an immensely
powerful post of gravitational energy a
big gravitational wave you might say now
despite Einstein skepticism ever since
he came up with the idea of
gravitational waves scientists have been
trying to figure out how to detect them
and the combination of their efforts is
the lig oh the laser interferometer
gravitational-wave Observatory in fact
there are two of them simply put the way
the lig Oh
it has to incredibly sensitive arms each
four kilometers long and if a
gravitational wave does come by then the
two arms can measure the bending and
stretching of space-time in unison as
the wave travels through them and when I
say these things are sensitive
I really mean it like the tremors these
arms have to detect our minuscule like
the fraction of the size of an atom and
so on September the 14th last year early
in the morning the gravitational wave
that was created when those two black
holes collided over a billion years ago
finally reached earth and for the first
time ever scientists were able to
observe a gravitational wave for real so
why should you care well not only do we
finally have evidence that yes Einstein
was right but this discovery is also set
to open up a brand-new way for us to
observe the universe so far we've only
been able to do astronomy using light
this started by seeing things we have
normal visible light and then moved on
to other parts of the electromagnetic
spectrum like ultraviolet light and
x-rays but the problem of all of this is
that only about 4% of the universe is
stuff we can actually see using light
the other 96% is known as the dark
universe and it's completely invisible
to us however now that we know what
gravitational waves look like the plan
is to figure out more about them and
then hopefully use that information to
try and build a new kind of telescope
that will allow us to see the universe
using gravity instead of light and
there's a chance as well this
information might allow us to
extrapolate back to probably the biggest
gravitational event of all of them the
Big Bang and learn more about where we
all came from it's kind of like we've
been watching the universe like it's a
TV on mute this whole time and we've
just finally figured out where the
remote is so I am incredibly excited to
see what new discoveries will be made as
a result of this and I hope you know are
- thank you very much for watching and
I'll see you in the next one goodbye
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool cheers again
for watching I am gonna link you to my
previous video over there some stuff I
enjoyed in January as well as a fun
science video I made about Saturn
because that one's quite fun also
I'm gonna be one of those annoying
people who makes an announcement about
an announcement but on the 29th I'm
gonna I'm gonna tell you for shizzle
what my book is about so be prepared for
that for now I'll just say that if you
enjoyed this video you'll probably enjoy
the book as well I hope that's vague
enough good bye